thing about Abba and preach that they
don't know about me
they they haven't they don't bother me
enough yet but I'll tell you this
I'm [__] insane
and if you and if you wanna if you want
to do the war thing that's my favorite
thing in the world but I'm close now you
know how we felt when you kept doing
that pause it uh-oh first of all
dumbasses you were being transphobic
just a bunch of those
um I mean he watched like Abba and was
Abbott and preacher you watch them a lot
no no it's peaches and cream peaches
same [__] I I have no opinion on those
guys because every time I've talked
about them they've cut like so many
videos giant pieces of [__] I yeah
they're [__] and they're I think
they're like um
they can sometimes be like agreeable but
I think that's why it's like kind of
Insidious where they're soft they'll so
you think like Europe what are you yeah
that's like the Pillsbury Doughboy
looking at you going you kind of frumpy
yeah
it's like dude really you can sometimes
be like agreeable but I think that's why
it's like kind of Insidious where
they're soft they'll they'll come across
like reasonable at certain points and
I'm sorry you'll see something so
unhinged I'm like what the [__] no I'm
sorry y'all guys get in front of the
camera and talk like your his definition
of unhinged is just saying that trans
women don't belong in women's sports
whoa points and I'm sorry y'all see
something so unhinged I'm like what the
[__] no I'm sorry y'all guys get in
front of the camera and talk like you're
preaching dude you guys are soft they
take [__] out of context or try to like
quote unquote dunk okay but all of that
aside
okay I think I think it demasculates
them and that's why I like it
[Music]
oh these guys are so masculine it gets
on my nerves they need to be
demasculated so pieces and Community I I
don't want these guys to be masculine so
let's be masculate them and that's gonna
be right it's better it's funny how
mother hold on it's funny how
[__] are always the first one
to be oh you know what gay this day that
lgbtq mumbo jumbo whatever the [__] and
then the first chance you get to
weaponize that [__] you do it there you
go Ethan I'm soft okay you a [__]
you a whole [__] and you
instrumentalize all that [__] that's
what you do oh no games this gaze that
equality all that good stuff but the
minute you want to weaponize this and
I'm gonna tell you all the people from
the lgbtq community just notice this
[__] from people that say that their
allies to you okay watch how they move
to insult other month that's being you
when you got a bunch of people on your
side and they're like yeah yeah what's
wrong you get you probably take an
Indiana
they thinking what you are
they taking what you are and then using
it against another person that's not a
night eye let's just also appreciate
their way to insult us is to make us
sound more feminine
oh yeah it's feminine so it solves for
it's bad that's you I don't even care I
don't care but that's you that's what
you do I think it's funny when someone
says like yo people it's funny because
the red pillars do the same thing yeah
they'll try to make you sound more
feminine oh that's feminine energy you
do the exact same thing and this is why
we tell you A lot of these feminists or
red pillars are two sides of the same
coin when it comes down to it and they
get upset they use the exact same
language notice we never said Ethan's a
feminine type of dude easy could have
done that we don't because I don't lose
anything wrong if you're a feminine
masculine man go ahead live your best
life but for these guys that's actually
a bad thing so no matter how much they
trade any of these virtues when it comes
down to it when they gotta get dirty
they use the exact same ammunition but
there have been times I think I think
one that comes to mind listening to
Jordan Peterson that you described as
probably being someone that would be a
bottom that's the only one I can think
of off the top of my head but like I've
I've heard you at times made me say like
oh this is someone that might be a
bottom you can't always tell like who's
the top who's the best do you find it
offensive if I say by being like oh he's
he's probably a bottom is that the
problem
absolutely it's offensive um because the
gay men already you have to you have to
deal with certain assumptions about
femininity and masculinity I mean it is
funny though I just that's all I'm
asking for is just be a little more
conscious of it so would you consider
yourself a top or a bottom or you don't
do that the labels and I mean this was
all peace and love and with the respect
Ethan it's none of your business but you
have a preference one way or the other
but that's another dangerous assumption
too can I guess you tell me if it's
right if I guess right if you're on the
bottom it doesn't mean you're like a
beta you could be Alpha and also still
be on the bottom uh but but if you were
does it does the poop pass like any
differently from before is it all normal
functions like I I get it it doesn't
leak out but I wonder if it just comes
out a little the labels
yes
just understand like I said I don't
really care that you call it peaches and
cream apples and Peach whatever and the
reason you do it I think nicknames like
that are funny you guys constantly
police other people's language talk
about this is transphobic this is bruh
have you heard yourself thing about Abba
and preach that they don't know about me
they they haven't uh they don't bother
me enough yet but I'll tell you this
I'm [__] insane
and if you and if you wanna if you want
to do the war thing that's my favorite
thing in the world but I'm close they're
they're just they're they're pathetic
they're Liars they're dishonest and
they're phonies
they're not even genuine that's the
thing right here look at this I like how
it sounds quiet like man I don't want to
be involved in this nonsense so it's
like fuel I'm gonna be honest with you
guys this whole like internet War beef
is the most corny [__] on the [__]
planet like I know sometimes we've been
like covering people multiple times we'd
be like oh there's a b yeah we just
cover it because it's relevant and
people want to see it people think going
back and forth is just a war like I
don't to me that's just a cringy
language like people use the most
violent like oh I got bear smoke for
them intellectually like just say you
gotta rebuttal and just get you're just
using words this is so stupid can you
imagine two intellectuals be like we're
gonna verbally joust in an intellectual
Warframe like shut the [__] up how old
are you what is this what is this it
feels like a manga for like YouTubers
it's Digimon no there's like a whole
showing it like this is just this war is
serious this internet is not serious I
turn off my pc I go outside I have a
good life nobody cares in real life
nobody gives a [__] about any of us
people go out to their jobs none of this
matters so just calm down with the whole
War I mean look they they're like uh
they're like at the edge of the
manosphere and they make a lot of they
used to like own a lot of manosphere
guys but then they also have some like
conservative points of view they've
they've cultivated a big brand for
themselves they came out they're they're
like not that this is you know I mean
you're comparing them to like some of
the worst people but like they're I
guess they're better than fresh and fit
and stuff for sure like well that's what
we've debate about them that's no I'm
just saying like they are more agreeable
like they are as far as I know and their
politics might have changed but it seems
like they're like you know
anti-overt white supremacy stuff like
that you know what I mean they they do
the thing on that I feel like they
become a gateway
I feel like they the first time they
talked about me was defending fresh and
fit right it was so bizarre this girl
called in and was telling us about this
horrible date she had with the fit
and then they Def and then they make a
video saying how like she's a liar and
[__] I don't I didn't watch it today I
watched I watched some of it but it was
upsetting so I didn't watch it
again why are we watching this you were
soft yet you're the one that got the big
words but don't watch the [__] that we
do you said we're just we're cutting you
out but you just admitted you don't even
know the context of what we said and you
call this a liar you call this a liar
figured out when you lied we said you
said that we clip you say that we take
things out of context but you just said
that we don't watch you don't watch your
[__] how about this how about this Ethan
for such lives and so disinterest just
do a live stream and showcase how we
took things out of context where the
greater context and if we're right and
you showcase it I promise you I'll get
up here online and the next day I'll
admit I'm wrong okay well you haven't
demonstrated that you just keep
repeating these talking points like your
Trump where you can just say things and
people are supposed to believe it I
watched I watched some of it but yeah it
was upsetting so I didn't watch it
they're centrists you know yeah yeah and
we know what that means kind of um
he's not I don't know you know what
kills me about this he was like yo it's
so crazy they defend no we just defended
was you making up at false accusations
or having Brown someone come on who made
false accusation and was easily proven
to be a liar okay that's what we talked
about the same way when the Buddy's
sitting right across of you Hassan was
accused by somebody else even though we
don't like him as an individual we still
defended him why because on principle
the person who was lying against him was
out here and I hope that Hassan actually
says something about that because when
he was accused of something he didn't
mind when other people went after that
girl and said yo she's lying but then
when it's actually fit all of a sudden
we're evil people for doing the exact
same behavior it's a bit bizarre but
anyways like I said y'all live your best
lives and like I said I don't know
enough about them I just I have seen
like although so some of their
commentary on like trans issues and it
just seemed like a you know cookie
cutter uh transphobic [__] uh and it
pops off you know there's definitely a
model there's definitely an audience for
it
um I think they they also loved when
like uh Gideon uh is funny looking at
the landing page right now because you
just see like all the thumbnails and I'm
like damn I want to click on those
he's not Victor
I'm like I could
I could I did that and this is the first
time I get to just see the hotel I'm
like oh [__] is this what y'all see I
would click on it too you know your face
is very clickable my face is lickable
yeah like when I'm doing the thumbnails
I swear to God so people don't know this
I just take it still from the video yes
I don't like make you pose or nothing no
no none of that it's always a still from
the same video so I just pick a moment
in the video right and every time I'm
looking for my face I'm like [__] why
am I face so poor and the preacher's
like
it's not even like oh I always want to
put it's not that you just have better
facial expressions I guess you don't
think so hold up minor that I guess this
is mine yeah this if I do this in the
video it's going in especially if it's
creepy mine is uh
yeah that's a good one
I don't know why when someone playing
the trumpet like a [__] always makes
me laugh yo I don't know whenever I see
a marching band and they're terrible I
start crying I actually cry you ever
heard a terrible marching band that [__]
funny
[Music]
I just feel like when I hear someone
who's terrible on the Trump is just
going on I just feel like nature around
them dies
blah
[Laughter]
said that I was
implied that I was a pandering or I was
like oh no sorry I was uh
patronizing to him
hold up I didn't imply that you were
patronizing to meet multiple people
imply that you're patronizing to them
and I will say your tone right now
sounds very different it doesn't sound
nearly as patronizing but there are
times on your stream where you talk to
minorities and the way you talk to them
is incredibly patronizing which is just
a fact you're just a trans you said that
like a lot of minorities say that that
the way you talk is patronizing so
listen you can take it you don't have to
but you have to understand if you're
speaking to that community and a lot of
members of the community say you sound
patronizing there might be some truth to
it I felt very very very very very very
very patronized watching his video is
what we should you aren't exactly a wash
of trans debate I hope I hope that the
rest of your life is as horrible as it
is every single day okay there you go
suck my dick I despise you I despise you
more than anything else on the planet
you are [__] cancer you are just a
trans person sorry you don't know what
the [__] you're talking about
you're just a trans person that's [__]
up that sounds patronizing if if we take
that and then we give it to you you're
not gonna use them no that's not passion
I think that's just you know uh yeah and
it's okay I get it like when you're
online and you're constantly under
attack by people and you feel like
you're correct on an issue sometimes the
100th person might be the thing that
sets you up and your tone is just crazy
and that's the one that gets clipped up
and used every time and maybe you're not
always like that and that's possibly
true but in those clips that we saw you
definitely sounded incredibly
patronizing but you know it is what it
is do you but I'm I'm down you guys you
know what I mean like I'm looking for my
next uh dragon you guys aren't a dragon
though you guys are like a gopher
we haven't hit that Echelon yet yeah
you're right how are you mad at it
though what's wrong with that that we're
a gopher like people like oh y'all
haven't hit two million years like yeah
maybe we'll someday maybe we never will
who cares you know one of the most
beautiful things about being on this
platform is like being where we are
we're already Extremely Blessed we were
blessed when we were at one million we
were blessed when we were at 500 000. so
anything above that is a blessing you
know sometimes people try to use the
numbers to like put us down like hey you
ain't four million it's like yeah [__]
but how many people are where we are
like let's just count our blessings and
be happy where we're at when you get
bigger great if we don't we don't but we
already have a great fan base very loyal
they really show out for the videos they
show love and so I'm super appreciative
so you know I'd already changed my
family's life who cares you know
like that's a thing people are like are
you excited to hit 2 million I'm like I
really don't care y'all [__] changed
my life already
yeah how could I ask for more yeah you
know what I'm saying
you can hit the patreon and you can sub
to the patreon for sure but like how
could I ask for more you can subscribe
if you're watching because like 25 of
you are not subscribing you just be
watching but I can't ask for more
there's also merchandise in the
description box so if you wanna you know
what I'm saying yeah there is more it is
what it is I'm not gonna ask for it but
if you happen to click on it [__]
go for around three one two three go
first
you know what
people like that anything they're
insulting us yeah
that's more merch for us
more merch we're gonna put out a shirt
called team gopher yeah and it's
basically a code name for us team gopher
right the channel does well they're no
their numbers are good but their numbers
are really good they know they know the
algo they know how to play it no their
channel does really good it's impressive
the numbers they pulled hey we
appreciate you guys hey we appreciate
you thank you hey you homophobic Kings
we appreciation hey that's nice of you
okay because yeah our numbers are been
pretty good lately you know pretty good
but again if anyone's starting a YouTube
channel and you guys are taking off I
want y'all to know something YouTube is
like this
you're gonna have months where your
[__] numbers are dipping like crazy
and others where they pick up are you
like yo am I falling off people not care
or whatever like you gotta sometimes
just chill on the numbers and getting
too caught up into it it's appreciative
because you get more money but
understand even though we're on a high
right now it might dip at any point so I
don't get too caught up in it yeah Tom
mans once said uh this two shall pass
good was that him uh you said something
like that I don't know where he took it
from but I know that did he take that
from Jesus
but how are you gonna allow a white man
to plagiarize Jesus I don't care I don't
I don't care you're gonna let a white
man please rise another white man the
white man yeah I don't care
but Jesus wasn't white
ah here we go
oh Jesus
hello my dark purple beautiful African
queens good day in pan-africanism my
brothers
today we are brought here to discuss the
history of Jesus and who he was and he
was not a white man I repeat he was not
a white man
yeah
they said it in the Bible that Jesus of
Nazareth had nappy hair now let me ask
you rich man from the caucus mountains
has nappy hair
oh wait
and I know I'll be waiting a long time
but I'll wait the way they appropriated
Jesus is the way the appropriate
Africans from Africa and brought them on
the slave ships to America do not let
them lie about your history peace and
pan-african is Jesus Christ
Consciousness over coochie
politics over punani I repeat
Consciousness over coochie politics over
punani I don't even see what the point
of this is and now you mean correlation
because men out here are sucking and
driving for that punani
the reason why they say Jesus is wife is
for that poonami
yay they used to like own a lot of
manosphere guys but then they also have
some like conservative points of view
they're they're like not that this is
you know I mean you're comparing them to
like some of the worst people but like
they're I guess they're better than
fresh and fit and stuff for sure like
well
that's no I'm just saying like they are
more agreeable like they are they're
centrists you know yeah yeah and we know
what that means
is this any different than the people
that you're [__] on they literally
just throwing a bone to like
the people that hate us just because of
our politics yeah I guess it's no
hanging fruit there's a market for it
yeah certainly and they're they're
capitalizing on it that's what it is but
you're you're right in the way that like
I see them talking about like this just
pearly things like they they do have
like takes that I think are that's why I
said they have they have a lot of like
agreeable takes and then they have like
some where it's just like oh wait wait
wait wait sometimes we agree sometimes
we disagree oh my that's life sometimes
you're gonna agree with someone and
sometimes you're gonna disagree these
[__] believe in a thousand
genders but can't believe people hold
two different opinions yeah
you guys believe that there's a whole
[__] Spectrum when it comes to human
[__] gender expression but you can't
believe that there's a spectrum when it
comes to opinions no there's right and
wrong get the [__] out of here man like
it was so it was so disingenuous when
like
uh that's when I realized like that's
actually when I changed my policy of
like uh I like how they're looking
through our YouTube titles to see like
how they can make a narrative about us
realizing like there's one video on the
cut there's one video talking about
Charleston white one to Doodle Kids
there's one video about pranksters going
after people in their regular jobs
there's one video right here that's
actually about Hassan being false
accused which they glossed over very
conveniently so they're they're trying
to pay to narrative as they're looking
through the thing but you realize
they're not making anything very solid
so they're just rambling but anyways
keep watching and the scroll is is hard
yeah
say what you want if it was so flagrant
it would have been [__] boom here you go
yeah boom there boom no they've been
scrolling you keep scrolling there are
videos of two months ago and why do we
put out five videos a week come on now B
this is the thing I used to run this
problem with keemstar where no matter
what I said and did he would in bad
faith just come up over me and say
whatever and I found out the best way to
combat that in my case was to talk more
and I'm [__] love that game dude like
if I love it I I don't love it I like it
you're way more combative I uh it's fun
but the thing is they're going to leave
me alone
leave me alone that's what Sebastian
Sebastian hit it this is their favorite
guy who begged me
that's their Idols
I told them I was like why don't you
guys watch the whole video and then come
tell me how embarrassing I am let me
think about it you don't even watch the
videos
it's so crazy you said you call those
liars and friendship Defenders without
watching the video and then you get
Madness for now asking the irony is we
link to your original videos as you ask
people when I watched the original and
came out to the same conclusion wow okay
either you don't even watch the video
either keep it simple if we made up so
many things and lied about you get your
team of researchers do whatever you got
to do and let's just see it let's see
you go through all the times we took you
out of context and misrepresented you to
the point where it made us look this
engine since you liked that game so much
and I promise that game in front of my
audience in front of the world in front
of even Black Jesus himself if I'm lying
I will come up here and I will apologize
and add no extra fluff to it okay that's
all think about it hold on hold on
anyway can someone watch this he has a
video of him with Rolo Tony Brown down
saying they're coming after us is he Pro
roll a brown town can you just preview
they're coming after us I want to see
that I would be genuinely shocked if
that were the case they're probably
making fun of him I hope so that would
be great
that's how [__] crazy just because he
watched he watches just part of this is
that like a lot of the people that they
feature in their commentary are
oh people that like hold on you're
getting roasted here
if you play Hogwarts Legacy you pass on
the other one that we were uh you are
you [__] you saw that right
you passed the thumbnails when we defend
the dude that's next to you and you went
right to the other wow you a [__] you
are a [__] yo it's actually insane how
disingenuous this man is it's it is
actually a Friday you can literally see
him scrolling as he's lying it is crazy
and you calling us a lie yeah you
yeah you like oh I got
that's crazy right dude they make they I
don't agree with them ideologically I
don't agree with like a lot of the stuff
that they uh make uh they I think do uh
way better commentary and and way more
interesting uh commentary than uh yeah
which is like literally [__] 14 year
old like that almost sounded like a
compliment until you said you're better
than fresh and [__] I was like saying
hey you don't smell like a trash bag
thanks
[__] that buddy
Hassan is a giant hypocrite is the title
of this chapter
I was wrong who's a massive streamer
speaking on this the only reason why I'm
not playing this game and I know a bunch
of other people are not playing this
game is because we know that it's not
worth it to get bullied endlessly and
called transphobic endlessly in it when
we have massive uh queer communities and
audiences that's it hold up
you're not playing the game because you
don't want to get called transphobic
endlessly now you know how we felt when
you kept doing that pause it uh-oh first
of all dumbasses you were being
transphobic
[Laughter]
I appreciate the way he did it first off
dumbasses I look I love I got it like no
no I kind of like that [__] it was kind
of though the way pause that [__] he was
super soft and then when we got to him
they're obviously just butt hurt at you
and I operating out of bad faith that's
it you're not playing the game because
you don't want to get called transphobic
endlessly now you know how we felt when
you kept doing that pause it
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transformed it's just grieving so like
he was mean to us so we're gonna yeah
man you [__] got me transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobes transphobic transphobic
transphobic transphobic I don't know why
it's even funnier watching him watch
himself say transphobic 100 times and
just see how awkward it is
this is probably the most rewarding edit
I've ever done watching him react to
himself say transphobic a million times
is actually one of my greatest editing
moments but anyways and I want people to
have a more positive approach to dealing
with issues transphobes transphobes
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic transphobic
do we dislike these guys probably Ethan
more so than Hassan but it's fine it's
just you know listen I don't dislike
Hassan specifically because of his
politics I think if you're some
socialist or whatever the [__] he is
like it's cool go do your thing I just
don't like the way he engage in certain
topics and I don't like the fact that
he's the very bully that he himself to
cries but he also shows Nuance every now
and then and he shows good takes on
different topics so I don't really have
that much of major issue Ethan on the
other hand I think he's just a different
issue but yeah
whatever it's not that big of a deal I
don't take this stuff seriously so you
know if they want to start a
quote-unquote war and be all corny and
[__] let them do whatever they want let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below if I hate you I gotta
hate everything that you do